[non-english speech]
Are you listening to me?
Of course.
You were sleeping.
I wasn't.
I promise.
I was having the most
wonderful thought.
Oh, yes?
And what was that?
It's been bothering
me for over a year now.
How does something
traveling to nothing?
What are you
talking about, Albert?
I imagined I was riding
alongside a light beam.
Guess what happened?
I have no idea.
Let me show you.
Come!
Come on!
[gasps]
Come!
Imagine I'm a light
beam traveling to Earth.
Now catch me!
How fast must we go?
About 300,000
kilometers a second.
Albert, you are mad!
No, I'm away, traveling
through the ether.
Come on!
[woman laughs]
Catch me!
[playing violin]
And if you catch up to me,
the strangest thing happens.
I appear to slow down.
Am I right?
[playing violin]
[woman laughing]
And here's the best part.
When you are traveling
the speed of light
alongside the wave, me,
I appear frozen in time.
Is that it?
Well, so far, yes.
[playing violin]